a guy who was not a first round pick in
2010 chris sims rob gronkowski he felt
around two because of health concerns
became a first ballot hall of famer at
tight end retired after the 2018 season
and here we are on this wednesday
morning one day before the draft
waking up to the news that rob
gronkowski happened so quickly late
yesterday afternoon one development
after another before you knew it both
teams were announcing the trade that
sends gronk to tampa bay gronk plus a
seventh round pick from the patriots for
a fourth round pick
from the buccaneers out of retirement
after one year honoring his contract one
year left he's going to make up the 10
million dollars in tampa bay reunited
with his good friend tom brady there
will be more dancing one way or another
from rob ronkowski in 2020.
yeah well i mean it's awesome it really
is it's not shocking but yet it's still
like
you know surprising i guess you know rob
gronkowski told us you know when there
was a rumors there the year the year
before you know that off season before
his last season remember we had been
told that new england had called detroit
tried to trade rob gronkowski things
like that he was on the market gronk
made comments like he'll never play for
another quarterback other than tom brady
and you know i believe him i of course i
believe him now but i believed him then
i think there is you know a true bond
there he's been spoiled by the new
england way by brady throwing them
perfect passes all the time he just goes
but why would i want to deal with
anything else you know but i think the
new england way kind of wore him out and
his body's feeling rejuvenated and he's
probably talked to brady a little bit
and he sits there and goes man okay
tampa florida the team looks exciting
what tom bruce aryan's awesome to be
around okay cool let's do it oh yeah and
you'll give me 10 million dollars okay
let's definitely do it so uh it's
amazing it just adds to the excitement
i'm excited for you know my old city
there tampa bay because this is a fan
base that loves football the guy they
fly a little under the radar and they're
getting a real treat this year with that
football team
hey i want to see gronk party with carol
baskin
i want to see girl okay
they won't be feeding gronk to the
tigers that's for sure they're going to
be feeding the tigers to gronk when
gronk takes over tampa although we are
not advocating the consumption of tigers
that is just to play on words all right
one point that we didn't make last hour
that i think is very important that we
get to the idea that the buccaneers had
to give up anything to get rob
gronkowski he doesn't play for the
patriots anymore he's retired he was
never going to play for the patriots
again look the problem is when you
retire and the team puts you on the
reserve slash retired list
you continue to be the property of the
team indefinitely until they release you
from the reserve retired list so if
somebody else wants gronk or any other
retired player
they're on the reserve retired list of
another team that team
can finagle something out of it and the
only way that gronk could have combated
this chris would have been to just
unretire and join the patriots again
like brett favre did with the packers in
2008. now with farvin the packers in
2008 the packers had the caps base to
reabsorb what was a 12 million salary at
the time for brett favre
the patriots don't have the cap space
and wouldn't have had the cap space to
take on that 10 million dollars that
gronk is due to make this year they
would have had to have cut him or
dramatically restructured deals or cut
someone else or done something to get
under the salary cap and they wouldn't
had a long time to do it so gronk could
have done that the buccaneers could have
gotten him for nothing if he had forced
his way out but he just didn't want to
do it i was told look this guy's got a
good or a good relationship with the
organization in new england he doesn't
want to screw that up
and so at the end of the day the
buccaneers had to give up something to
get a guy who was never going to play
for the patriots ever again and it
really is found money for the patriots
they got something literally for nothing
because they were never going to have
gronk on their roster again
well yeah i mean first off i mean it
sounds like gronkowski brady and neither
one of them i don't think want to screw
over the patriots uh you know they're
always gonna have a special place on
their heart for that city the
organization everything they did there
and yeah that was the common text i got
from my friends
why did tampa trade anything for him why
didn't they just force new england just
to be in cap hell like you just
explained and then have to cut them and
then get them for free and i thought
yeah that doesn't make sense i don't get
that and then i thought about what you
said just there a second ago oh the
relationship he doesn't want to screw
them over but then i thought deep a
little more deeply about it mike and i
thought
wait
if
new england was going to get
compensation back because new england to
me mike and you you correct me if i'm
wrong i think they could hold the
oh we think you tampered with tom brady
and rob gronkowski tampa bay buccaneers
and either we have a trade conversation
here or we'll call the league office i
mean do you think that's a possibility
that i have no knowledge of that but i i
would think that goes into this
conversation a little as well
i think it's one of those weapons that
maybe the patriots didn't have to reach
for as related to buccaneers because
because they've used it in the past
right we've seen tampering allegations
made by the patriots we've seen them
made against the patriots there was that
stupid one the jets made simply because
robert kraft mentioned darrell rivas
after he'd left the patriots and signed
the jets several years ago but i think
that from the buccaneers perspective and
you know you and i have heard
the rumors and the rumblings and it's
all uncorroborated and unsubstantiated
but look i remember after brady did the
deal with the buccaneers how hard the
buccaneers were trying to sell to the
media the idea that bruce arians the
coach of the team jason light the gm of
the team didn't talk at all at any time
ever to brady until the wednesday night
that free agency opened
when the deal was already done we
already knew a day earlier he was going
to tampa there's no way in hell tom
brady's going to tampa without talking
to bruce arians and jason light ahead of
time about that deal there's no way
that's happening so maybe they already
knew they were on thin ice and yeah you
think about all the possibilities and
maybe you entertain the idea that hey
gronk all you have to do is show up and
say
hey you got to deal with my 10 million
dollar cap charge i guess you have to
cut me you're right at some point you're
going to stir the pot enough
that it's going to potentially explode
on you and you're going to be dealing
with a couple of tampering charges from
the new england patriots as de brady and
as de gronk so maybe that's another
reason why it didn't progress but at the
end of the day look
it shows you the value of having an
organization that engenders goodwill
with its players we talked last hour
about deandre hopkins how badly he
wanted out of houston he would have done
whatever he had to do if he had to make
an aggressive stance he would have done
it and he did gronk wants to have that
relationship with the patriots moving
forward he wants to have their
relationship with boston moving forward
as does tom brady and i think it makes
it even more important that it's not
perceived that you're screwing the
patriots on the way out that's right
yeah i think so i think you're exactly
right let alone we know the gm jason
light down there in tampa he worked in
new england i was there with him for a
short time before he had moved on i
believe to arizona uh after that and
he's a good guy and i think he left on
good terms in new england as well to
where i don't think he's trying to look
to screw over the patriots completely
either so yeah i mean i agree with
everything you said there and i of
course think brady and gronk don't want
to be viewed as villains to the boston
fan base
but you know i i think i'm just
fascinated by it from the football
standpoint because to me
now
tampa has kind of what new england has
had in their prime there's three
offensive weapons on the field where if
you're i don't care how good your
defense is you go
damn i don't know who to stop between
gronk
mike evans who's one of the three or
four five best receivers in football and
chris godwin who's in the conversation
for
top 10 top 12 receiver you know this is
where you get to be a scary offense when
you have this many talented moving parts
that you can you know change formations
and move people in different spots to
where it's going to make it really tough
on on a defense let alone mike if they
can get a right tackle and and their
14th pick of the first round and then
the one thing they're missing i look at
if they get a running back like if i'm
tampa i'm looking to trade up in the
second round and pick have my pick of
the litter for running back and if they
have that
oh my gosh i mean go for it tampa do it
you know right now you got a team on
paper that can win the super bowl and i
think you got the leaders in place to
keep that on track and actually win a
super bowl or at least be there or be in
that conversation and to me that would
be the last piece of the puzzle if they
can get that real difference-making
running back which i think they'll be a
lot there to have early in the second
round uh i just look at the tampa bay
buccaneers and go oh my gosh they're
gonna be so good they might be one of
the best teams in the nfc
but but let's not let's not crown them
yet i know i know yeah because here's
the thing here's the thing yeah when
brady and gronk were together in new
england they benefited from
a defense that was skilled and a
defensive mastermind who knew how to get
the most out of them
and there weren't major concerns about
the defense being not good in tampa
there are concerns about how good the
defense is going to be and also the
offensive line if
what was the big discussion after brady
signed in the bruce arians offense the
quarterback holds on to the ball a long
time because they want to throw the ball
down the field and if you hold on to the
ball too long and you're 43 years old uh
you may not be on the field for very
long so there are some concerns i think
right when it comes to this buccaneers
team because they don't have dante
scarneckia they don't necessarily have a
dominant offensive line or anything
close to it and their defense is a work
in progress so uh yeah there's there's
reason there's there's reason to not
schedule the parade for early february
or whenever a parade would follow the
super bowl this year depending upon when
the season starts and when it ends but
uh
they've got concerns that are going to
be glossed over as we get caught up in
this frenzy
yeah no doubt about it you know and you
know you can also say hey we think the
tamp you know the team itself even
without brady or grumm you know it's the
second year with todd bowles the second
year with bruce aaron's you would expect
things to be better and smoother
all of that but mike you know i'm glad
you brought this up because we didn't
get to this in the last hour but we
talked about like
maybe how we were talking about teams
that might like tua that trade out of
the top 10 to maybe get him
tampa is one of those teams that when i
was sitting there doing my mock draft
that i went
man
because to your point they need an
offensive lineman specifically a right
tackle i mean right now joe hague is
their right tackle i don't think that's
going to make tom brady feel comfortable
i could see them being a team if they
see a certain run of tackles go off in
the top five or six picks that they
trade into the top ten and just go okay
we're going to get one of these tackles
that we like right now and not risk
sitting here at 14 hoping there's one
there i think those are those are like
another thing i look for in the draft
tomorrow night because i got to think
their number one concern is hey if we
want to throw the ball downfield if we
want brady to work for two years not one
we got to make sure he doesn't get the
the crap kicked out of them and i i just
think there's a real possibility they
might be a player to get up into that
top ten to get get one of those tackles
they like
yeah and i'll tell you what they're
going to need it they're going to need
it on the outside they're going to need
it on the inside because we've seen over
time the way that you get the brady the
way that you rattle brady the way you
beat brady is with pressure up the
middle in his face he can navigate when
the pocket collapses on the outside step
up step left step right that right very
very subtle movement where he slides and
he anticipates when it's coming straight
at him
he's not nearly as effective so they
need all five spots to be effective they
need to feel good about every offensive
lineman and they got to get them maybe
maybe they can get dantes garnekia down
in tampa bay to help out he is retired
although he was out of retirement to
help the the new england patriots at the
scouting combine however they do it
though i think there are going to be
some concerns that need to be addressed
and as you said the draft is one place
to do it there could be other free
agents they add uh they need that
defense to be better and they need that
offensive line to be good enough and
they need to have the time and the reps
to get ready for the season that's the
the limitation for everyone this year
but as you're trying to throw all these
parts together the teams with continuity
are going to be in in a better position
to win chris these teams that are
throwing things together on the fly are
going to have even more of a challenge
to be as effective as they can be when
it's time to play the games that count
no doubt about it you're right the teams
that are bringing back their core group
of players that haven't had as much
movement i think do have an advantage
and especially you know hey with this
instance here yeah quarterback learning
a new offense he's been in a certain
language for 20 years this is going to
be totally different for him you know
getting gronk on the same page you know
i don't know you know yeah it makes you
question is tampa gonna be able to
unveil
the full force of their offense early on
in the season they might have to be a
little simple just for everything to be
cohesive and on the same page but you
know i doubt that too you know i think
you know brady is extremely smart
individual i think he's out to prove
something right now we know that gronk
the same way and i think that they'll do
their best to really keep up the speed i
wouldn't be shocked if brady's having
like a zoom session with left witch and
bruce arians daily for hours at a time
where they're teaching him the offense
and the nuances and the little things
like that
yeah look there are clear limitations on
what can and can't be done and i
remember when you got john gruden got
back into the nfl two years ago he was
upset that you had limits on the amount
of time you could work with your players
i have a feeling those rules are being
mildly fractured in this upside down
topsy-turvy off-season definitely
definitely mike you know because if if
you know you got a player who's all in
on football right and he loves it he's
not gonna tell i mean i would have been
one of those guys i would have been like
you know hey gru i'll be there tomorrow
yeah i know we might not supposed to be
there but i'll be in the building if you
want to watch some film do something
like that screw the nfl in their rules
i'll work as hard as i want to thank you
very much nfl i'll deal with the hell i
want to do as a player and when you have
those kind of guys on an organization
the coaches know it and then they can
coach them and break the rules and know
that they're not going to get told on
and i think there's a number of those in
every organization and i certainly think
tom brady is one of those guys as well
yeah i want to know if the rest of the
story of tom brady being chased out of
the closed public park in tampa included
an older gentleman sitting on a bench
with a kangaroo
you know what i've never heard anyone
really do a bruce aaron's impersonation
but based on the one you just did i
never want to hear it again
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports